this is the Google home it's a I really
know what to call it actually except
that it's kind of Google's version of
the Amazon echo it's like a voice
assistant in a box
it's basically a bunch of microphones
and a big speaker that are designed to
give you access to not only your music
but to the Google assistant that is
really what Google announced today at
this big event so you can do things like
say ok Google changed all my lights to
red or okay Google play the Luke Cage
trailer on my living room TV this
assistant understands what's going on in
your house is connected to the Internet
and it's able to be sort of the
go-between for everything everything you
can do with the assistant on your phone
or on the other devices is also
available here you can get directions
you can look up information you can see
what's on your calendar it's a really
powerful and personalised box because it
has all this data about you and it's
always listening so you can network a
bunch of devices together or just yell
from across the room the Google home is
coming out November 4th it's 129 dollars
and it might go a long way towards
making this kind of box something a
fixture in everybody's home